[Music]
you are bothered by the fact that people
in your opinion don't make eye contact
anymore they don't have you noticed that
I've noticed it when I try to have
meetings that people have their devices
now and they're looking down and you
probably I'm just wondering have you
noticed it like in your life when you're
talking to people you're dr. Phil I
would think people would look at you
when you talk but nobody looks at
anybody anymore do you
yes I'm looking at you right now I some
say I look a little too long and too
hard yeah but you know you and I inter
no I like to really lock in with someone
and stare at them but you and I
interview people and don't you dread the
death guess it comes out here and stares
at you like a dead trout you're obsessed
with trout tonight I'm gonna sing I'm
telling you that I think that I'm quite
good at making eye contact have you
found that with me been on this show a
bunch of times as a guest and I usually
like to get right in there
some women have complained on the show
well I don't think I don't really notice
you making eye contact but I really
can't take my eyes off your hair so you
can say you might be jealous this might
be making you angry right now feeling
even feeling you sweat so much hair
that's moving around an orange and it
looks like a desert I might be jealous
but I might not be you don't make a lot
of people that don't make eye contact
it's usually because they're hiding
something really yeah so when someone
looks away from you that's one of the
ways that you know that they're there
though I thought that about you before
that you were hiding something I just
didn't know what
I'm not hiding anything I think I know
what he's hiding
well I mean he is behind a desk so maybe
there's something going on behind the
desk that he's hiding I'm not wearing
pants interview no I I have to say I
I don't think I I think I have
unfortunately beady little eyes that is
one thing that I have is I have little
little Andy don't you think that's true
little yes I do - like we have the B
Deus dies on television yeah do ya
really tight on Andy's eyes and my eyes
get really tight Wow look about them get
me those are pretty too now Andy's are
pretty lizard-like yeah yeah what's
wrong with mine yours are pretty creepy
creepy i sleepy uh you're a doctor and
that's your diagnosis hey doctor what's
wrong with my eyes they're creepy
you